los bosques asiáticos diezmados
sustituidos por palmeras de aceite o
hebeas miles de hectáreas de Selva
brasileña quemadas a causa del cultivo
de soya es para luchar contra estos
fenómenos devastadores que el parlamento
europeo y los Estados miembros de la
Unión Europea han firmado un acuerdo
histórico
cacao café soya pero también aceite de
Palma madera carne de vacuno y caucho a
partir de ahora se prohibirá la
importación de estos productos si
proceden de tierras deforestadas después
de diciembre de 2020 un gran paso
adelante bien recibido por los
ecologistas es la primera vez en el
mundo es el café que desayunamos el
chocolate que comemos el carbón de
nuestras barbacoas el papel de nuestros
libros es radical la decisión de la
Unión Europea no sólo cambia las reglas
del juego para el consumo europeo sino
que crea un enorme incentivo para que
otros países cambien sus prácticas
varios materiales asociados como el
cuero papel impreso o carboncillo
también se ven afectados las empresas
importa tendrán que demostrar la
trazabilidad de estos productos una
decisión sin precedentes mientras que la
Unión Europea es responsable del 16% de
la deforestación mundial lo que le
convierte en el segundo mayor destructor
de bosques tropicales por detrás de
China la ong wwwf lamenta sin embargo un
acuerdo imperfecto sobre todo porque aún
no se refiere a otros ecosistemas
forestales amenazados como la sabana del
cerrado en Brasil la ongs lamenta que la
protección sea demasiado precaria para
los pueblos indígenas porque se basa en
la legislación local que es desigual de
un país a otro